[Music]
[Applause]
Marcus Spears of the mothership NFL
analyst you can see him at four Eastern
weekdays on ESPN Laura Rutledge Ryan
Clark Mina kimes Dan Orlowski which fan
base should feel worse today big swagoo
Washington commanders okay Commander oh
listen man I
first of all you could see the
frustration balling over from everything
that's going on
um Rover there having to clear up
calling out Carson Wentz last week and
saying I didn't mean that it's a lot of
I didn't mean that going on in
Washington right now they need to figure
something out
um
it's bad when you you win a game and you
do what you do what Ron Rivera had to do
in the locker room after the game like
so it just tells you about the culture
man and this is the this is the
antithesis of it starts from the top
yeah okay that is like if there was any
definition of usually your company or
whatever you're associated with is gonna
be a reflection of the person that's in
charge well here's your definition of
that
um
winning or losing but you can see it man
you could see dejected
um especially with the way the game was
played you get a win against Chicago who
is who everybody acknowledged before the
season is not good and it didn't even
feel like a win BP I don't even but it
didn't even feel like a win I agree yeah
it's one of those we won let's not spend
too much time celebrating this but but
I'm trying to assess Justin Fields I got
an idea who Carson Wentz is going to be
the rest of his career
uh Justin Fields I just don't know
because normally a Young quarterback is
not playing on a really bad team they
would ease you in but now when they
draft you first round top 10 your plan
right away no matter what the lineup and
talent level is around you well here's
the problem
um
and I'm so glad we have an example of
how much coaching matters
do you see what brand day bowl is doing
in New York and remember how we talked
about how terrible the New York
offensive line was and how bad Daniel
Jones was what we see in coaching
overcome some of that but but explain
what he's doing though okay so
just strictly on the field DP from a
football context
a lot of it now is Daniel Jones on the
Move using his athleticism I.E that's
what Luke gets he should have did last
night okay
um max protection keeping six or seven
more or more guys in to give Daniel
Jones that time because his ma Daniel
Jones mind has been warped from his
early years in New York like he's
dealing with what he was dealing with
what we're watching just the fields deal
with right now but just like Sam darnold
did with the Jets absolutely I can't
tell you how many times last night
looking at that game where in two
seconds just the fields had to get out
of the pocket or he was getting hit the
dude got hit so much last night I didn't
know if you he laid on the ground after
like four hits in that game and I'm
thinking like what is happening right
now with this offensive line so what
they ball has done is he's identified
his best player on the team to saquon
Barkley
his quarterback has been in a bad
situation and now I'm going to coach to
his Elite abilities Daniel Jones Elite
abilities is his athleticism and his
accuracy how he can place the ball so if
he has time and getting him away from
the rush he can actually throw the
football in complete passes unlike
Jessica Fields last night with Lou getsy
you keep doing three and five step drops
standing him in the center of the pocket
knowing your offensive line isn't good
and you expect something to change he's
not there yet with throwing the ball
with anticipation it takes most young
quarterbacks a year or two to figure
that out in the NFL game that your guys
open when you don't think he's open but
you're not giving them a chance with a
bad offensive line and and obviously uh
with the play called like I I just don't
even then it was such a bad display of
football last night on both on both
sides but I just I I don't know if
Justin feels mine isn't going to get
Warped in Chicago if they don't make a
significant change with how they're
playing and also get some Personnel
around it great throw to Mooney for a
touchdown he bobbles it yeah a great
throw on the touchdown like the dude can
throw and we know he's an elite athlete
but they keep dropping him in the center
of the pocket and just telling them to
stand there and play football and I
don't agree with that even though he can
do it his team is not where it needs to
be yet for him to be able to do that
he's Marcus Spears from the mothership
you can see him on NFL live uh weekdays
at four Eastern Troy Aikman's quoted as
saying that the Cowboys should look at
keeping Cooper Russia's the starting
quarterback if he happens to win this
game against Philadelphia DP
I knew he was gonna do it
I knew you was gonna do it man I don't
know what the hell wrong with everybody
okay listen this is as simple as this
and I keep saying it I even cursed on
Twitter okay I curse a lot on Twitter
but I cursed on Twitter about this
when Dak Prescott is healthy enough to
come back to play he's going to play let
me put that out there I this this great
Mojo all of this all of this Karma all
of this all of this stuff okay it's
great I'm happy for Cooper rush I'm
happy that the Cowboys are winning you
don't know one bigger fan outside of
Michael Irvin than me or the Dallas
Cowboys that's in the national meeting
so I get it and I'm excited about what
Dallas has done I think I think Kelly
Moore deserves as much credit as anybody
because he's actually had to kind of
Step his game up and figure out ways to
get this offense moving but DP we know
the test is this week
and I'm telling you right now you ain't
gonna be able to throw for just a
hundred yards with zero touchdowns and
win this game
as good as the defense is in Dallas and
I think they are Elite as it gets when
it comes to all of the units in the
league
this is going to be about your
quarterback making plays continuously
throughout the football game that's the
type of pressure that's going to be put
on Cooper rush and then if he responds
and answers great and if that gets
healthy that could be playing against
Detroit
I also wonder though and I said this to
Chris Collinsworth yesterday because
they have the game on NBC on Sunday
night you have a blueprint here for
success
right you're running the football
playing great defense
when Dak comes back
why not adhere to the same blueprint now
you might throw it a little bit more but
it doesn't feel like that's what's going
to happen here so explain that to me
Marcus that's why that's why me and you
here DP because before
Cooper Rush played a game
everybody was alluding back to remember
last year when he played against
Minnesota all the year that guy heard he
played against Minnesota and he threw
the ball all over the yard and had a
tremendous amount of success
um and that's the game that everybody
relatively start talking about like this
is who we can be with Cooper Rush no
Kelly Moore decided okay I got an
offensive line
that is coming along with a bunch of
guys that's playing together for the
first time the easiest way to build
rapport with an offensive line is to run
the damn football everybody that's been
covering football for any length of time
knows that that is how you jail an
offensive line as fast as possible and
then once you realize or if you realize
you can do it you can build so much
around that we did a eight-minute
segment on NFL live I think a week ago
about the play action and how important
it has become again in the NFL
everything has been so spread out
everybody was in shotgun every play and
the Cowboys finally had the Epiphany
that even when they built the team when
that took over for Romo this was the
blueprint that they wanted to use we had
Ezekiel Elliott as one of the top three
running backs in the NFL the offensive
line was one of the best run blocking
offensive line and everything for that
worked off play actions is very similar
to what we watching right now so yes
keep this same template now DP doesn't
mean you're going to be able to no teams
get better and you're gonna have to
throw the ball you may find yourself
down I don't know what this defense if
you're gonna find yourself down too much
so you may be able to stay within what
you want to do but ultimately man yeah
and this is why Kelly Moore deserves
some credit and maybe by his by none
none doing of his own but you know when
you take a step down with the ability of
your quarterback you have to become more
creative as an offensive coordinator you
got to figure out ways to help this guy
in certain situations and if you keep
the same energy when that gets back what
I've been seeing DP is receivers that
are wide open off play action I've been
seeing Tony Pollard touch the ball a lot
more I've been seeing Zeke being used in
between the tackles and on the perimeter
all of these things become stagnant when
you got that because you want to Tee It
Up and throw the ball 40 times and have
the number one offense in the league
instead of winning games the formula for
Dallas these past four wins have been
take care of the football run the
football and don't put out defense in
bad situations and it's it's paid
dividends for them
should the Chiefs be underdogs to the
bills at home
no
no I grapple with this one DP because I
love first of all both of these teams
um and I do believe the bills from 1
through 53 is probably a more talented
team outside of the quarterback but I
think Pat makes up for like three guys I
ain't gonna even lie bro I'm not being
I'm not being I'm not trying to be funny
I think the dude make up for three guys
like whatever you lacking I think he
makes up for in a way now you can't
overcome certain things as a quarterback
but his offensive line is is solid I
know Brown gave up a lot of a lot of
pressures to Max Crosby uh last week but
I really believe this team like the
Chiefs man or
I think we we've we've just gotten tired
of seeing the greatness of Patrick
Mahomes and Andy Reid okay and this
Buffalo team when they added Von Miller
obviously brought him over because of
what happened in the playoffs last year
but Patrick Mahomes been playing against
people like this since he got in the
league he's been playing against Elite
rushes he was under a lot of duress
against the Las Vegas Raiders new had to
come back from 17 pointers now in that
game
um so I I just
I know we just can't get fatigued of it
man like it what they're doing and I
know missing Tariq is a thing but what
he's been able to do and what he's been
able to accomplish like throughout the
duration of his his time and for this
team not to be changed as much as we
think they're they're actually solid on
defense I thought that would be their
Achilles heel they're solid on defense
not great but they always they make
opportunistic plays
um
I just don't see Patrick Mahomes being
an underdog at home unless he playing
with four or five guys hurt and that
ain't the case in this situation
great to talk to you have a great
weekend thanks for joining us as always
my brother you know it I'll talk to you
soon could you put Mike Greenberg in
that safe right behind you could you
like what is in that safe right behind
you it's a a lot of dpuc yeah you see my
you see my deer right there yeah
fish we going fishing tomorrow actually
um but my my guns are in that safe okay
yeah wrong house to try to enter okay
laughs
all right my brother thank you ma'am
thank you very much all right okay
Marcus spirit ESPN NFL analysts